I'm looking for buying Jack Sparrow
I need to speak with you Henry you sold
either absolute resoluteness I'm
currently one two three so not a very
good clapping and this is for a Pirate
Captain Jack Sparrow it's today's your
lucky day as I just happen to be Captain
Jack no it can't be
I've spent years searching for this the
great Jack Sparrow is not some
drunkenness sell-through even on a ship
a crew pants a great pirate does not
require such intricacy do you know how
long I've been waiting for this moment
the risks are taking to be here you sure
you're lean Jack Sparrow how would you
like to die pirate hanging firing your
invention the guillotine guillotine
they're French
I love the French did you know that
they'd invented my name how bad could it
be it's French hey
ah here's an idea for one with her good
old-fashioned standing I I killed mr.
not now get the crowd involved doesn't
it
I should like to speak the vicar in
every level like a singer Lee Harvey I'm
not one can play normally this baskets
for the head
you